la jeunesse en ce moment elle ne voit
pas l'avenir la délinquance c'est quoi
si c'est un peu de désespoir quelque
part les spécialistes viennent de
prouver que la délinquance chez les
jeunes est en nette progression est en
nette recrudescence
à quoi attribuez vous ce phénomène trop
de facilité souvent trop d'argent et
surtout si des parents non seulement
pour passer à quoi attribuez vous madame
le phénomène de délinquance
aujourd'hui en france mon dieu la
délinquance et des jeunes qu'on peut
être pu être qui sommes pas bien dans la
société en fait je sois tellement aux
fréquentations des enfants peut-être un
manque d'éducation
ils ont un peu trop de liberté à mon
avis est fréquente beaucoup les cinémas
ballet d'il ya quoi c'est toujours les
places dans les cités qui sont visés et
puis les films de gangsters sur mon la
pauvreté ils auront leur idole ali daei
et d'autres plus beaucoup de répression
ou et à mon avis principe de prévention
les enfants ne non plus le respect de
leurs parents comme il l'avait dans le
temps je pense que pas des délinquants
que la faute les temps modernes
je crois que nous sommes plus dans le
coup on est un peu stressé tous parfois
j'ai envie d'être délinquante aussi
quand je vois certaines injustices et
pourtant j'ai la cinquantaine donc
[Musique]